Od teleskopów po Wielki Zderzacz Hadronów —
każde nowe narzędzie naukowe rewiduje pytania,
które my jako naukowcy
i ciekawi świata możemy zasadnie zadawać.
Wysokowydajne przetwarzanie, czyli HPC,
dołączyło do tej elitarnej listy w latach sześćdziesiątych. Dziś
komputery kwantowe pukają do tych samych drzwi.
Witajcie, nazywam się Iskandar Sitdikov
i jestem inżynierem oprogramowania w IBM Quantum.
Na tym kursie chcemy nauczyć studentów
i specjalistów, jak quantum computing wkrótce będzie
współpracować z infrastrukturami HPC,
żeby zapewniać moc obliczeniową.
Dowiesz się, jak komputery kwantowe
i klasyczne komunikują się i wymieniają dane,
jak pisać programy wykorzystujące oba typy sprzętu
i jak ta integracja otwiera zastosowania, które możemy rozwiązywać już dziś.
Zdobędziesz praktyczne doświadczenie z prawdziwym sprzętem kwantowym
i klasycznymi klastrami wysokowydajnymi,
uruchamiając zadania kwantowe obok tradycyjnych obciążeń HPC,
a także nauczysz się interpretować wyniki z pewnością siebie
i rozpoznawać miejsca, gdzie akceleracja kwantowa
faktycznie może pomóc w obliczeniach,
a gdzie nie. Przede wszystkim zrozumiesz,
dokąd zmierza przyszłość komputerów
i jaką mapę drogową tam obierzemy. Uważamy,
że ten kurs jest zarówno ważny,
jak i aktualny, i wierzymy,
że łączenie tych technologii będzie kluczowe
dla osiągnięcia przewagi obliczeniowej.
Może to mieć szeroki wpływ na różne branże,
takie jak chemia — umożliwiając potencjalnie
szybsze projektowanie leków i badania materiałów —
finanse
— dla lepszych modeli ryzyka
i wykrywania fraudów — oraz sztuczną inteligencję i machine learning
do optymalizacji modeli. Na tym kursie
zagłębimy się w zasoby obliczeniowe,
modele programowania i algorytmy kwantowe,
więc witaj i przygotuj się —
jest dużo do omówienia.